votre nom c'est francine cranie principe
gagner qu'est ce qui vous attire un reer
radio internationale parce que j'ai des
beats by ok c'est super intéressant de
venir voir comment ça se passe derrière
les micros derrière la caméra fait que
c'est vraiment le faire alors un petit
mot pour les éditeurs à travers le monde
dit comme on le dit à mieux écouter le
cimetière de cailloux de musique
accueille toujours le même en commun
travail comme d'ailleurs le cadavre
qu'on ne voulait pas classe le plein
alors qu'est ce que vous avez vu mais
j'ai dit bonjour vietnamienne partout
dans le monde
est ce que j'ai reçu comme bonjour mais
il faut accepter les différences des
autres autour des différents
alors c'est s'accepter excepté les
différences arrêts merci beaucoup
alors bonjour le monde
je suis maintenant en direct des de la
journée de la culture de la grande tour
de radio-canada à montréal
je vous salue et je vous embrasse sa se
voit tomber visite à radio canada à
cause de la culture pour du tout non les
déshabituer on vient à chaque année
on prend plaisir à visiter des petits et
petits coins comme ça alors ça se fasse
ce matin la visite depuis que des
pierres ça se passe très bien j'ai eu la
chance d'établir des contacts avec des
personnes ressources qui vont pas
probablement m'aider dans mes études et
de mon espace est pacifique et fait
vraiment de belles journées
bonjour je suis très très contente
d'être ici aujourd'hui dans la journée
de la culture
et puis je trouve ça très très très
important qu'une personne puis je bell
visitez puisque présent je rentre
d'edina merci je trouve ça vraiment très
bien fait est ce que vous avez entendu
des radios comme à l'international
non non non nous diffusons 25 langues
arabe mandat
et espagnol est-ce que vous parlez
d'autre à part les français n'ont
malheureusement mais récemment radio
canada international
je suis montréalaise j'aime les gens
nous sommes reconnus nous les québécois
ray canadien grande des gens
accueillants mais nous sommes surtout
des gens humains alors moi je m'en ce
message d'amour à travers le monde
le message de paix d'harmonie
en espérant que tous les peuples et 6 à
combattre plein de choses qui se passe
là l'environnement tous aussi désolant
de voir ce qui se passe en indonésie le
tsunami
je vous demande de faire attention à
l'écologie vous avez écouté parler de
radio canada international
non moi j'étais la première fois en
temps des bruits de radio canada
international
c'est que ce serait plus plus de 70 ans
je m'appelle j'y semi nous écouter radio
canada international